so many uses but so little time
good evening my name is Gloria Borger
and Borghi bhaga bhaga boo let's just
jump into it Tyson my name is poppy
Harlow and welcome to piñas the most
respected trusted news source of all
time especially here on YouTube thank
you very much
now our first story comes from goose
Wayne last week pide pide did a video on
goose Wayne who appeared on dr. Phil
people that are breaking the wall and I
try to bring them to justice
now it turns out goose Wayne has
responded in the most epic way pocket
you're not supposed to say that
so Steve just sent me a reaction video
comes up for me
I'll be watching I'm a supporter now
I'll protect you when you come to
Florida well concerning all the Florida
memes it looks like I am needed
wait he's from Florida it all make sense
now
police say man with no hands and no legs
is armed and on the run in Florida it
all makes sense now
we need goose wait in florida florida
mcdonald's 9-1-1 and demands a ride home
to change his underwear
we need goose lane in florida yeah so I
have never subscribed to anybody before
and uh so yeah but it's about time
I liked I liked it I liked the video I
thought the editing the editing could
have been better the editing some
constructive criticism on the video I
appreciate that goose Brad - or sigh
however is in deep pain I hope you
realize the pain and suffering you have
brought the punch side I want to cry
you're the first person L subscribe to
the first person oh come on yeah right
here I'm just gonna boom
and yet the notification Thank You GU
Swain very be cool on behalf of
PewDiePie of course I'm just popping
Oreo Goods Wayne man what a legend thank
you very much namaste
like I said though the editing haha
could have been better the editing could
have been better you hear that side the
editing could have been better
everyone's been tweeting this to Brad
because everyone thinks Brad tweeted I
mean and Brad one left a response
I cannot imagine caring about anything
less and also sigh bedded in the video
so y'all can stop asking me this now but
we are one of the same brand that's
right equal rights equal opportunities
thank you very much I'm hungover man so
my bad I know this ain't like a good
video or whatever but he literally has
prawn open on his chrome are you kidding
me see that's the thing I saw this an 18
year old blond elf with braces 18 year
old elf with braces gets tucked in bye
Santa
bye Santa I'm not supposed to give my a
bucket all right I'm sitting like saying
stuff like that I'm like he's obviously
trolling maybe he's half trolling I
don't know I do know for a fact that I'm
very proud of you guys for being so nice
and supportive and not just going whoa
what an [ __ ]
dick therefore f this guy or something
like that you know there was some really
constructive comments in there
I was also genuinely concerned because
like I made the video and I wasn't sure
if he was real or not just because it's
such a weird story about a man that
refuses to listen to his fiance and he
just want to be Batman right before
their wedding and he had like the
censored version of his wife in the
banner so it's kind of like oh god but
he tweeted out that he's gone on his
first date in two months with his
fiancee with no masks and I paint you
nine-year-olds help me love myself more
than you know it's no longer Felix its
dr. Felix what a nice wholesome message
he said that he read a message that he
was inspired by a message saying goose
it's not about the mask it's about the
man behind
masks and I really helped them so I
think that's really cool I'm really glad
I also saw a video that he made with his
fiancee so I'm glad they're still
together and it was obviously very sweet
and it made me think wow this is
actually real I actually don't even
really know who cutie pie is you don't
even gotta post anything we're just
going to subscribe to PewDiePie for you
okay okay number 12 the you know goose
might have mental issues when you first
got with him oh my god yeah so yeah I
don't know I think that it seemed like a
positive development and I'm I'm happy
to see it I don't know that's it comes
from James Charles is in the news again
what the James Charles do this time big
oopsie massive oopsie James Charles
tweeted what's your favorite step of
your makeup routine
mine are eyeshadow and baking solely
because I love how it looks
LMFAO then some random guy posted this
tweet saying absolute wanker simple as
they nothing more to it what an effing
wanker AF okay AF thank you for your
input now so fun posted to this guy
another photo of James Charles saying
thoughts on this part question mark she
could have it fella nothing wrong with
pink hair would smash after a few pints
AF now a lot of people were quick to
point out to this gentleman that it's
not a she mate that's James chops this
got retweeted everywhere and it got a
lot of attention on Twitter people
started reposting it and to ridicule
this guy and he was not having it and
posted this if this isn't removed in 48
hours you're in massive trouble bonds
haven't stopped taking
out of me for this calling me gay bent
[ __ ] shagger really started to piss me
off
delete or consequences a F delete or
consequences I never seen a more
threatening response he gave 48 hours as
well very generous
he then after noticing that this was not
slowing down whatsoever this AF man
decided to make an official statement
that's right an official statement came
out from this individual you might want
to grab a tissue this is very sad they
on the 18th of January I was the victim
of a largest of large-scale deception
and fraud a man masquerading man skating
I think it's a right term as a wyman
managed to fool me into stating I should
shag him ah this is shaking me to my
core been feeling sick upset angry
gutted now I can't show my face in
public without receiving comments and
speculation on my sexuality this has to
stop this has to stop
immediately I would never never shag a
bloke never James Charles should be in
prison for fraud this can't be real like
this can't be real I am the victim
victim of a hoax designed to bring my
sexuality in question anyone taking the
piss of me it's getting reported to
Twitter no warnings no second chances
this incident has left me scared to walk
two women in case they are transgender
sickening I am the victim here signed as
a Quebec what an amazing signature
where's everybody three-year-old Jesus
Christ he then started threatening James
Charles basically indirectly because
people pointed out that he was in
Birmingham at this time James Charles
should watch his back he then got
deleted on Twitter because people
reported him obviously this is pretty
terrible behavior and honestly I mean if
it's real it's a pretty shocking
reaction I mean obviously the homophobia
is bad but looking at its handwriting
he's clearly not the smartest individual
so maybe it's not the most surprising
reaction either but a good good old
laugh
regardless very nice thank you James
Charles very cool next week we have an
update on the roblox ban of PewDiePie
next week Peter Pan was banned from
roblox and I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but this is probably one of the
most grievous offenses of all time this
is reported on every new size of all
time as well because of how important
matter it was the verge post said while
Peter pied treated the entire affair
like a joke like a joke do you think
this is some sort of joke
The Verge huh what did you go copy
strikes and people criticizing you
The Verge okay but I want at least 500
roblox as an apology and I also want a
written apology saying subscribe to
PewDiePie to show that you don't support
T series and he also gave them 25 hours
to respond and lo and behold roblox
responded PewDiePie posted on Twitter
there is a God my roblox account was
unbanned PT 1 2 3 t32 has been
reinstated incredible I've never been
this happy there is hope there is faith
in humanity faith in humanity restored I
also personally hacked pity PI's email
to get the response from roblox and it
states as follow in December Peary
became negative memes on roblox and we
began blocking the creation of new
usernames that incorporated PU die
legacy account that Felix used in his
livestream was incorrectly banned as
part of the in the ministration policy
goddamn it I'm bored
is that it is that all you got roblox
where are my 500 robots I'm not joke
otherwise roblox you're gonna be angry
alright I appreciate that yarn by my
account but a deal is the deal and I
said I said specifically 22,500 robots I
think since you miss correctly banned me
it's the very least you can do okay
thank you very much robux thank you I'm
waiting I'm still waiting patiently okay
all memes aside I actually am very
thankful to everyone that tried to raise
their voices to get me unbent I like I
don't care at the end of the day it's
just a meme it's not like I play roblox
or anything like that but I still
appreciate that people suck their neck
out for me especially in the roblox
community thank you very much I really
do mean it I appreciate it
and everyone who raised their voice I
don't think they would have unbanned me
otherwise or PewDiePie so I appreciate
it regardless next me Takashi 69 pleads
guilty to nine counts cooperates with
feds what Takashi
this might mean the Takashi six nine who
previously would spend 47 years in jail
which would mean he would come out on
the age of 69 which Woodruff's had been
the ultimate meme of all time that would
just be the best legacy you could ever
let leave behind but no no no Takashi
6-9 just had to ruin the meme I mean
what happened to the initial response
were Daniel Hernandez is completely
innocent of all charges being brought
against him ah what happened to being
innocent on all charges Takashi he
admitted that he paid someone to shoot a
rival rapper to scare him hero he also
admits finally to be involved in the
gang I don't even remember what they're
called it doesn't matter a ninth ray
gang I mean to be fair most people would
probably ride out and to avoid that long
of a of a prison time but at the same
time I mean he obviously did a lot of
bad things if this is what he's involved
with and and when Takashi if he gets out
now I mean he's gonna be in trouble he's
gonna have to hire a lot of security but
the most important news out of all this
is of course
Takashi 6-9 for meme review confirmed
let's make this happen guys bye you know
news chuck-e-cheese that's right there's
a conspiracy going on popularized by
Shane Dawson that the pizza slices from
the Chucky Cheese are always uneven as
followed in this image here why are the
pizza slices uneven aren't they supposed
to be cooked as one pizza Chuck is
Chuckie Cheese reusing the pizza slices
from other customers that don't finish
their pizza to make a whole pizza the
slices don't add up Shane Dawson went to
Chuck E Cheese to investigate on this
conspiracy
[Music]
it looks like it was
[Music]
I mean this one is
[Music]
[Music]
he then asked an employee what their
response was so we walked over so we're
talking and then I say hey like what's
like going on with the betta it's just
like what do you mean she's laughing and
then she kept doing this for critics
ready ask me like what's going on pizza
okay what's going on with the pizza
No
okay so is it like do they put a bunch
of pieces together and she goes are you
filming
what is there's something going on now
chuck-e-cheese was forced to respond to
this conspiracy
a spokesperson claims unequivocally
false unequivocally false we do not
recycle pizza slices they also stated
that no conspiracies here that sounds a
lot like someone who is part of a
conspiracy would say chuck-e-cheese I
mean most likely what they do is they
cook a lot of pizzas and based on what
people order a half of something which
seems pretty common and they just
distribute the pizza slices accordingly
I mean that seems like the most possible
explanation and they probably don't want
people to find that out so that's why
they're just going no conspiracy I doubt
that they're reusing slices it just
seems like a high risk low gain kind of
a kind of deal where they would just
potentially harm their entire brand
based on just saving a few pizza slices
I don't really see that happening
it is funny though like I really enjoyed
this conspiracy and I think you know out
of all conspiracies is kind of one I can
actually get behind just because it's
it's a good life YouTube has stated
constantly that they are and they've got
a lot of blowback from the media about
conspiracy videos that YouTube
recommends conspiracy videos and that
they're saying that they will recommend
fewer videos about conspiracy theories
and that you can go down the rabbit hole
on YouTube I don't know what I feel
about that I think it's fine if you want
to enjoy conspiracy theory just realize
that 99% of conspiracies are false which
of course mean that 1% of conspiracies
are real and the chuck-e-cheese slice
conspiracy pizza reuse is confirmed I
rest my case here pew newts signing up
smash like check out new merch that's
right
very ant Oh God Jesus Christ limited
time only
very nice emerge if I may say so myself
and I'm not supposed to save that
thank you guys for watching another
video and I see you brooch skis on the
whole ski if you buy the merch and you
get the brofist okay how about that well
this is posture I'm bending over for the
sake everyone keeps commenting about my
pasta listen I'm bending over for the
sake of being in the shot alright do you
want the goddamn bro fitting you're not
no breakfast no breakfast
you get no brofist buy you want pyramids
we got them oh you're into casos huh we
got you covered baby you want some bets
easy we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit